first let's go to mark meredith standing
by at the north lawn of the white house
with more on what the president is
planning hi mark
eric good afternoon president trump
keeps claiming that he won the election
even though his court challenges about
this keep coming up short
and so many states are only days away
from certifying their results that
includes michigan they are set to
certify
on monday but today gop officials on the
state and national level
sent a letter urging the state to delay
its certification
they want to allow for an audit of the
results in wayne county the area around
detroit
republicans in their letter writing
quote we encourage the board to grant
the request made by john james for
senate he was the republican senate
candidate
and adjourned for 14 days to allow for a
full transparent audit of wayne county's
2020 general election results this is a
request at this point doesn't mean it's
going to happen but the president had a
chance
on friday to meet with republicans from
michigan some of those lawmakers
were basically there to talk about
what's been going on on the state level
including with the coronavirus
but after the meeting republicans who
met with the president insisted nothing
is changing on their end
as certification nears they wrote quote
we have not yet been made aware of any
information that would change the
outcome of the election in michigan
and as legislative leaders we will
follow the law and follow the normal
process regarding michigan's electors
just as we have said throughout this
election that's for the
republicans they met with the president
yesterday meantime this weekend what's
the president been doing
you're looking at it right there very
2020 he's been holding a meeting along
with g20 leaders
it looks like a big zoom call right
there they're meeting virtually for this
summit as opposed to doing it in person
because of the pandemic
the president's there in the second row
third picture down kind of hard to see
that's the only image that we've seen of
the president from that meeting today
we may get a better readout from the
white house a little bit later on the
president's been at his golf club
in virginia this afternoon unclear if
we're going to see him do any other
weekend events but he has another g20
meeting tomorrow eric all right mark
thanks so much
you better